now therefore whether you are thinking
about the total or the original makes a
really big difference if you're trying
to find the GST so for example to find
st from the original price okay you have
a choice you can say this in a lot of
different ways but we're going to be
doing the same calculation every time
you told me that this GST is a tenth
right it's a tenth of this whole
originally in fact if you've got the
space that you may even like to number
these you've got one two three four five
six seven eight nine ten
so therefore if I were dividing right
from the original price I'm gonna divide
that by ten and that will give me the
GST if that's what I want to find okay
so from the original price divided by
ten now dividing by ten is not the same
as what you said before or it doesn't
sell in the same anyway you told me was
10 percent right 10 percent so instead
of dividing by 10 percent as an
alternative what I could do is I could
multiply sorry I said divide by 10
percent instead of dotted by 10 I can
multiply by 10 percent these are the
same things but the reason why it's
helpful to have this here is because
you'll be working out in a second other
countries don't have such a nice neat
number ten percent they might have a Oh
GST or a value-added text of v18 all
kinds of weird and wonderful different
percentages like eleven and a half
percent seven point nine or anything
like that there you go so every every
country around the world if you've got a
different percentage you just want to
slide it in here it's much easier okay
but for our intensive purposes it's a
lot easier to think of dividing by ten
you have to worry about the city but it
also makes this next thing a lot easier
if you know how to find the GST from the
original price but instead from the
total price this is something that we in
Australia do very frequently because
remember I said the GSA's included
already you
okay so we're usually seeing the total
price not the original price so this is
something we see much more now looking
at our diagram over here right
you've got your one two three four five
six eight nine ten original parts and
then the GST is kind of like the
eleventh part does that make sense so
now think about you've got the whole
thing there right what you're seeing is
the blue and a little green trunk
altogether if you want to find the GST
now you don't divide by ten Dumon
because there aren't 10 chugs there are
11 chunks does this make sense so this
is the textbook causes the rule of thumb
all it means is well you've got 11
pieces now so don't divide by 10 divide
by 11
okay does this make sense so if what
you've been given is a price that's ex
GST excluding GST and divided by 10 and
have that on if you've got a price it's
including GST it's already added on
you've got the total don't divide by 10
divide by 11 and you can see why it's
the eleventh part okay now this is if
you want to find GST the last two you
think you need to do is sometimes you
want to convert between these original
and total you don't really care about
the individual price of the year so you
just want to work out what's one based
on the other okay so if you want to
calculate the total from the original
okay so you've bought something for pure
you're a business that sells things you
bought this wholesale you didn't pay GST
on it but now you're about to give it to
consumers and you're like well I've got
to work out how much I've got to charge
these people so I can give the
government the right amount okay so
you've got the original price you want
to calculate the total I could of course
just work out the GST and add it that
would be two steps though I don't do
that I just want to go directly there
okay so instead of dividing by ten than
adding that I'm going to multiply by now
I've got a choice you know up Otago he
said multiply by 10%
I catch the species a little bit well if
I want to include this if this is
tempers
and this is the original a hundred
percent I can do the hundred two percent
and the 10 percent all in one hit just
by doing a hundred ten percent okay so
you can just gently punch into your
calculator times one one zero percent
alternately if you like I don't I want
to do with the percent but anyway
instead of x hundred ten percent what's
that just as a decimal very good
so you can multiply by hundred and ten
percent multiplied by 1.1 same effect
okay last one if you want to reverse
things okay if I want to calculate the
original from the total grant actually I
literally do this like every week
whenever I order something the price I
see on the website it's you know it's
the total price that's what websites
always advertise because they're always
including PST but I need to know the
original amount because as the manager
of the math faculty budget I don't
actually have to pay you see the school
pay it for me that's jaunty sort of set
aside funds for that okay
so therefore I see the total price but I
only want the original so if this is how
you go from total to available right and
I want to now do it in reverse
what should I do instead of x should
divide
ah that's a great question okay can I
just multiply by 90% 0.9 okay now the
short answer is no but the real question
is why not
doesn't it seem like it should work can
I just think about this for me back down
let's think about the effect of
multiplying by 0.9 or all multiplying by
90% okay I'm so glad it's like I planted
you but I didn't right um what effect
does this have okay well let's think
about this it's the last stop we're
talking about right it's like you can
see the total question you want to work
out what the original is you want to
remove the GST out of that okay now if
you multiply by 90% that's like taking
your price and slicing it up into 10
chunks and taking one away
do you agree with that it's like look
here ten chunks and I only want nine out
of the ten do you agree so what I've
done is I have removed 10% but my
question is 10% Oh what what is the 10%
that I'm 10% of what that I've taken out
and the answer is it's it's the total
price that I'm looking at right it's the
total price I'm looking at the bigger
number okay so let's just think about
this with actual numbers okay this is a
bit hard spin that's right
suppose I want to buy okay let's see
let's keep it simple
I don't know how much the new iPhone 7
cost but I'm sure there's some model
that's pretty close to a thousand
dollars so let's see ten does anyone
know is that bad okay the eCos abysus
funnily enough that means it's um
probably in Korean geez
right so let's imagine this as our
original okay so I want to add on my 10%
now I want to go from on a calculate
total from this original so I'm going to
multiply by a hundred and ten percent
that's going to give me one thousand one
hundred is my total okay now you don't
even need a calculator for this right
think about it come on these are easy
numbers if you did this
if you multiply by point on it if you
multiply by 90 percent
um multiplied by 90%
that's going to become nine hundred and
ninety dollars but that's not what I
came from why isn't why didn't I get
straight back because Matt's okay come
on think with me right remember I said
to you what's the 10% you just want 10%
off of this yeah you'd love to mess it
up when you added 10% it was ten percent
of this number do you agree and then you
took off ten percent but the ten percent
you took off was not ten percent of this
number
it was ten percent of its not much which
is bigger which is bigger right whether
it's bigger or smaller than the point is
it's not the same ten percent
percentages change based on how big or
small you are that's kind of the whole
point of a percentage okay so that's why
no don't do that do that okay it's a
very common mistake to make sure we just
want to so glad it got us instead you
want to divide by this sort of divided
by 1.1 does that make sense